Speaker 1: Well, I am going to tell you
about a post today in which the failed
former President Donald Trump defecates on
the Constitution. Now, hold it. Whoa, whoa,
hold it. I'm not literally going to show you
scat videos, so don't you don't have to turn
away. You don't have to get the kids out of the
room yet. Although if absolutely brutalizing the
Constitution and using it like toilet paper
is offensive to you, then maybe you do want
to get the kids out of the room. Donald Trump,
in an absolutely constitution destroying rant,
demanded for a new 2020 election or to be
reinstated as president of the United States
under the continued false claim that he is the
so-called rightful winner of the 2020 election.
Trump exploding on his platform. Truth.
Speaker 5: Social Censure.
Speaker 1: Well, call it what you want over the
Twitter bombshell that flopped into a nothing
burger, saying the following quote. So with
the revelation of the massive and widespread
fraud and deception in working closely with big
tech companies, the DNC and the Democrat Party,
do you throw the presidential election results
of 2020 out and declare the rightful winner?
Or do you have a new election? A massive
fraud of this type and magnitude allows for
the termination of all rules, regulations and
articles, even those found in the Constitution.
He's literally saying the Constitution
is not the supreme law and framework of
the land. He's saying when we decide
there are extenuating circumstances,
you terminate. This is the word terminate. Rules,
regulations and articles. He goes on to say,
our great quote, Capital F founders. I don't
know what's weirder that it's in with a capital
after that it's in quotes it's both are weird. Our
great founders did not want and would not condone
capital F false and capital F fraudulent capital E
elections. The Constitution means nothing to them
if it's not convenient. This is brutal,
brutal authoritarianism. It's all meaningless
unless it is convenient to them. And there
Donald Trump says, I don't know. It just
sort of seems like we've got to eliminate or
circumvent better said the Constitution so that
he can somehow end up back in office. Now, think
for a second of the insanity of the situation.
Former president who lost and is again a candidate
is saying maybe just put me back in office. Maybe
let's skip me doing two years of a Republican
primary or a year, however, like a year and a
half and then a general election and then
having people vote. We can skip all of it.
Terminate as he says. What is he thinks he's
Arnold Schwarzenegger. Terminate the Constitution.
Maybe just put me back in power. And the most
insane part of this is Republicans aren't even
going that wild. It should be instantly
disqualifying. For a candidate for the
presidency to say, sometimes we terminate
the Constitution, we just terminated. Now,
if you want to have a conversation about we
need a constitutional amendment. Oh, okay.
Well, we have a process for that. If
you want to have a conversation about
should a document like the Constitution be
revised over time in some more general sense,
that's a completely legitimate conversation to
have. It's not about we can never. I'm not asking
to have it both ways, because many of us on the
progressive left say. A document that is this old.
No matter how great the intentions were of those
who wrote it and believe what you believe about
that. Right. No matter how great the intentions
were, no matter how much how forward looking
they planned to be, at a certain point, we have
to be able to say it needs modern context. And,
you know, you can argue about whether a few
hundred years is enough time. But do we think
that the Constitution would be relevant in 500
years, in a thousand years, in 1500 years without
significant revision or contextualization? Sure.
Let's have that conversation. But that's not what
Donald Trump is saying. Donald Trump is not
saying there are aspects of the Constitution
which in general need to be revised, modified,
amended, whatever the case may be. Trump is
just saying keep the Constitution the way
it is. Just ignore it when it comes to me.
Figuring out a way to get back into power. I'm
going to give you one example of a Republican
who. Seems like she's not going for this insanity.
Unfortunately, for a lot of them, they are going
for it. And we're going to get to that probably
on tomorrow's program. But here is Alice Stewart.
She is a Republican strategist, former Ted Cruz
communications director. She doesn't like this,
but there are many Republicans who are just
kind of like that. I mean, I don't agree.
But Trump may be the best choice we have.
Speaker 3: As divisive as him. And I hate
to inform the former president. The Constitution
does not like a spouse. You can't just get rid
of it when it no longer suits your purposes. The
Constitution is here to protect the rights of all
Americans. It is not there to change the past
election of a self-serving American. And he is
wrong on this. This is absolutely ludicrous. And I
guarantee you, Jim, the more you ask conservatives
and Republicans about this statement, they will
say this is not right and they're going to.
Speaker 1: Well, we'll see about.
Speaker 3: That right themselves
from these kinds of statements.
Speaker 2: Yeah, Alice, the Constitution
is not like the buffet at Mar a Lago. You can't
get past the items that you don't like. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Listen, I guess, you know, those things
have become the standard has become so low. I
guess I respect Alice Stewart for saying this, but
at the same time, all she's saying is we have to
mean it when we say we respect the Constitution.
You can't just ignore it when you just want to
use the you want to circumvent it in order to get
back in power. But it is absolutely not true that
Republicans are united against this. It should
be political suicide to say what Donald Trump
said to terminate the Constitution so that you
can get him back in power because of Hunter Biden
pictures. I mean, at the end of the day, that's
what we're talking about here. But we're seeing
mild criticism from some wings of the Republican
Party and this type of thing. I mean, you know,
in 2022. A lot of Republicans ran on the election
was stolen and they didn't do very well. So it's
at least possible, possible that some of the
mainstream Republican Party is going to be further
alienated by this insanity. Any clear thinking
individual who actually cares about the rule
of law, even if we believe that the Constitution
needs to be amended, updated, changed, whatever,
by going through a process. Not in a rush, because
we've got to terminate it to get somebody back in
power. We can do that. We can talk about that.
But this type of stuff needs to be rejected.